hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the final round of
the second day of defeated World rapid
Championship meaning that is round nine
it is Ralph mamido versus Andrei
yesipenko and this game is so short and
so uh abruptly and you will not believe
it you will not believe such a thing is
even possible in the early Lopez uh but
uh you know that is that is the way of
Chess and with so many games being
played in this Championship like I said
like 170 players I don't want to trick
you guys I'm going to check how many
players uh there actually it's 178
players uh some incredible games are
bound to happen and with that do both
game we've just seen uh time to check
out another crazy one so Ralph mamidov
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to E4 we have Ponte E5 Knight F3
Knight the C6 and as advertised The Rue
Lopez Bishop to B5 we have A6 uh it's
pink who goes for morphe's defense
Bishop to A4 and knights the F6 now and
here uh mostly played are castles or D 3
or D4 or even Queen to E2 but Knight to
C3 is somewhat rare but not not very
like incredibly rare it's the tarash
variation all right or or the three
Knights of the uh of the morphe's
defense and now we have Pawn to B5 so
very standard rule lopezian uh moves
with Bishop to C5 and now uh okay what
do you play here yeah you can see that
there are some tricks here like the E4
Pawn is weak the bishop here is very
strong so you might imagine something
like D3 being played or castles being
played but nope here Ralph plays Knight
the D5 and already uh you should you you
should feel that the E4 Pawn should not
be uh capturable like there's no way you
can you can capture this and uh come out
alive from this yeah I mean uh unless
unless you're thinking that white
blundered and move seven in in a in a
World Chess Championship which okay does
happen but uh that's exactly what um uh
what is being complete here uh he played
Knight captures and he 4 and it is now
as of move 7 that we have a completely
new game but believe it or not it's not
that easy to take advantage of this okay
the F2 Pawn is hanging so how do you
defend obviously you could Castle or you
could play Pawn to D4 which was played
in the game and now uh this is uh the
problem if espenko doesn't know this by
heart then he will have to calculate all
of this and probably he thought that no
way this works when he captured an E4
with the Knight but look at this if you
play e characters on D4 then the problem
is okay you're gonna Castle black is
going to Castle obviously black wants
the castle to save you as soon as
possible uh as he snatched some material
Rook to E1 the Knight is attacked okay
you go back Knight to F6 and Bishop to
G5 and how are you defending this uh if
Bishop t7 you even gladly give up the
exchange Rook captures Knight captures
Knight captures and F6 G captures and
Bishop captures and it's only it's a
matter of very simple Queen to D2 to G5
or H6 and you're gonna check with the
black king for example Queen 38 if you
want on Pint I mean we'd get the night
into the game just queen queen to C1 and
if Knight now uh if you play Knight to
G6 then just Queen to H6 and if you play
Knight to F5 to prevent Queen to H6 then
Queen to G5 check and that's it you have
to block with the Knight and this will
be Checkmate so uh E Capture Sun D4 uh
does not work so what what else can you
play uh you can move the bishop and the
best way to play is to move the bishop
to A7 uh or no best best way to play
would be to capture uh on D4 with the
bishop but this also means parting with
the bishop pair and when you grab a pawn
you part with the bishop pair you
instinctively feel that your opponent
does have compensation for the pawn uh
but it would be best Bishop captures
Knight captures Knight captures now you
play Queen to G4 put pressure on G7 and
then the Knight here and uh uh even
after castles you don't go for the
Knight you play Bishop to H6 you
threaten Checkmate here and after Knight
the E6 defending Checkmate now you play
Queen captures and E4 G captures on H6
and you get this extremely crazy
position where okay white will capture
an E5 the material is equal uh or rather
black is up a pawn but the black spawn
structure is much much worse than white
and let's say after Queen to G5 offering
a queen trade uh black defense white is
somewhat better but let's say Knight to
F6 you can always play King The King The
G7 and the winner win back your opponent
you open up a discovery Queen captures
Knight captures and now it's equal
material white spawn structure is better
white is better but black will be able
to fight so that's what happens uh if if
play captures on D4 and if you play
Bishop captures on D4 so the other
option is Bishop to A7 and in the game
Bishop back the E7 was played and this
also feels uh to be the the correct idea
like Bishop to A7 just seems too greedy
leaving your Bishop on this strong
diagonal so Bishop t7 is is always well
almost always considered a very strong
defensive idea but here it just doesn't
work and here why just castles black
castles and now Rook the E1 attacks the
Knight and how do you defend you you can
play F5 or anything like that because
then all sorts of Knight jumps become
possible like Knight captures an E7 a
double check from the Knight and the
bishop so you have to figure out
something else if you go back Knight to
F6 then just Knight captures an E7 uh
Queen captures and now let's say d
captures an E5 white is having an
excellent game so instead after Rook D1
Knight the D6 was played but now Knight
captures on E5 Bishop to F6 and now Pawn
to C3 and now Knight to F5 here whatever
black plays Black's position is so bad
and uh it doesn't really matter what
black plays he will not be able to save
this game Knight to F5 was played and
now comes uh the the move from the
thumbnail and that is Knight captures
and F7 it's not the only winning idea
like Queen to G4 wins night captures and
F6 wins uh and Knight captures and F7
wins so pretty much any any move with
with a beast here wins but this is the
nicest way to do at night captures on F7
and now if you okay if capture with the
King we're not even gonna analyze that
but if you capture with the Rook uh
which was played in the game now there
is only uh well there are a couple of
very good moves but there is one
crushing move for white so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finishing the game
in only 14 moves that's right we are
only on move 13 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on F6 with check this is what
Ralph played and it was in this position
on move 14 that Andreas pinco resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here the problem is if Queen
captures then Rook E8 is mating one the
The Rook of course is pinned by the
bishop you can't move uh if you you
can't capture with the Rook we've
already covered that and your only other
option is to capture with the g-pawn and
that also doesn't give you all okay
that's not your only other option you
could also play King to f8 but then look
at this you can't go to the E file just
Knight captures on H7 check King j8 and
now you play Queen to H5 and now the
Rook is hanging uh what do you play you
can play D5 you block the light Square
Bishop but now even Bishop captures on
D5 absolutely incredible stuff and now
if Queen captures again Rook to E8 with
checkbook effect and real characters
will be Checkmate so that if you really
don't want the capture but in the game
after Knight cap what could be played
after Knight captures on F6 G captures
an F6 the only other option that we
haven't covered would be met with Bishop
captures on F7 King captures and now
white just collects the material Queen
H5 check King to G8 Queen characters on
F5 and even though you're only down by a
pawn here as black uh sorry not not down
by a pawn by a pawn and uh by an
exchange there is no way you can play
this you can't move the d-pawn like if
if D6 then Queen to D5 check picks up
the Knight even if D5 sort of to get
back into the game it's a very just easy
win like Queen to F3 and now if you try
to get the bishop into the game Bishop
to H6 and again there's nothing you can
move here it's just incredibly
incredibly bad if 97 you can even play
uh Rook captures Queen captures Queen
captures on D5 and pick up the Rook on
A8 so uh it's pointless to even Analyze
This so that's why after Knight captures
on F6 is pink resigned and a spectacular
victory for for Ralph mamidov uh in this
uh really really cool line of the of the
Rue Lopez here you can see this Knight
to D5 I mean this is something that you
you will see and I I almost exclusively
do this in bullet games and Blitz Games
uh but here in a world rapid
Championship you just don't expect
something like this to be possible but
still he went for the pawn uh he knows
that he probably shouldn't but
um he he as he he never saw the position
I believe he just thought that uh maybe
Ralph was just being overly ambitious
and that he will be able to just snatch
the pawn and Castle to safety uh but no
the game concluded extremely quickly in
only 14 moves uh sorry that didn't
happen Knight captures on F6 and there
he resigned so incredible stuff and as
this was again from the final round I
will also show you guys
um uh the standings uh let me just check
if I if I have them ready
uh yeah these are the sort of the the
standings of uh several players uh let
me just fix that a little bit yeah what
is this
something weird uh okay
there we go
yeah these are the standings via chest
24 Twitter uh so as you can see Magnus
uh in Seoul first place with seven and a
half points uh and a shared second place
Vladimir
and the Vincent kaimer then with six and
a half you have Daniel dubov
arjune
Fabiano caruana uh uh
who lost the Magnus Crossing in the
final round uh otherwise he would also
be much much further
again Alexander grisho Graf Mahmoud of
Alexis
so those are the top 20 currently there
are four more rounds that will be played
tomorrow so we'll see if Magnus will be
able to uh to maintain this incredible
pressure towards his opponent or will
someone else be able to overtake him uh
it it will be a great day for chess uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it be careful when snatching
those pawns uh I would like to thank Ben
Edwards Lars Oliver groundhog uh Jeff
Graves David Oxley and Kevin Clark for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day